[Musique]
celle de king of pop en serveur on se
retrouve on était encore cette 1ère fois
qu'on s'est vus on va tourner nos
derniers épisodes de la flamme de jeu le
prime
où tous les candidats se retrouvent un
mois plus tard
[Musique]
là je pense que c'est la plus longue
cérémonie qu'on va vivre de toute ta vie
de toute la vie entière 38 jours de
survie 16 aventuriers deux finalistes un
seul vainqueur bienvenue sur le plateau
de la finale du flambeau les aventuriers
de chupacabra
on était au mexique maintenant on est à
paris ont fait la grande émission où on
élit le grand vainqueur et originaux
compte aussi traîtresse en gros ça vous
voyez je suis encore fait peu
d'animosité envers moi oui oui c'est
clair les complots se révèlent les
trahisons c'est un peu on lave le linge
sale et en même temps il ya une espèce
de classe et de retenue quand les
candidats ou qui m'étonne toujours quand
je les regarde c'est à dire vous êtes
éventré important pendant toutes les
émissions puis là tout le monde se parle
entre amis il ya donc on a vraiment
essayé de respecter ça moi je veux
retenir simplement les bons moments ben
ça va pas être le cas la regardez bien
ces images vous allez vous fâcher bon
évidemment c'est le moment où on ressort
aussi les derniers conflits puisqu'on va
on va élire les lucquois le le gagnant
absolue du truc ciara qui mérite de
gagner c'est toi
c'est quand même
ça et je vais choisir m'a
jeté mon nom des pourritures de gaza
mais
ça fait sacrément est en fait envie de
voter pour aucun des deux elles sont à
égalité d'ailleurs tu vois ils sont
obligés de s'en sortir avec une ultime
épreuve l'épreuve dite
du baiser de la mort
[Musique]
voilà ça se jouait sa voix soit sont
rien d'autre c'est pas simplement parce
que c'est la mauvaise réponse mais ça ne
peut pas marcher tout vous l'avez sorti
pendant le quiz c'était déjà un miracle
que ça fonctionne j'avais que ce à quoi
l'on marque en vainqueur ce n'était pas
une évidence à l'écriture on a on a
essayé de tourner les choses au maximum
soso
l'enfant d'une association et vont bien
se régaler s'appelle
effectivement soissons
[Musique]
c'est pas moi
rigueur
ouais je trouve ça génial que les idiots
gagnent
ce mec a rien aucun talent aucune
connaissance stupide et vous centrez
qu'à toutes les tares en fait je faisais
même pas les qualités de marque envoyé
juste touchant parce qu'il est trop bête
et c'est toujours hilarant un gars qui
gagne qui arrive à passer les étapes
alors qu'il n'a aucun talent emploi
on est dans une vraie période où ce
genre de galles gagne chauffe et en vrai
ça c'est pas si à côté de la plaque d'un
truc qu'on vit tu as je trouve que
vraiment l'idiot crasse y aller elle et
elle prend beaucoup trop de place et
elles gagnent beaucoup trop de combats
[Musique]